what is up there citizens of the reject
Nation thank you so much for joining us
on this Wednesday journey and thank you
to all who have been subscribing that
means the world subscribe and click the
notification Bell do that do that be
great join the reject Nation leave a
like leave a like for Wednesday Adams
and how good this show is John how are
you I'm excited and spooky and all the
things how are you good I'm excited to
reap what I woe alrighty guys also full
interaction watch alongs where you sync
up with your own copy of Wednesday
available for a super sexy rejects over
at our patreon page thank you to all who
have joined our page so far and uh if we
cover several shows over there
exclusively with the reaction highlights
and watch alongs included gonna mention
that every every intro you know how we
do alrighty guys well let's get to it
how well do we really know our parents
not well at all I was accused of a
murder that took place right up there
which leads me to wonder
1990. hey
[Music]
foreign
's fault they were fighting over her
it's because he didn't go to the Raven
with you
I love it
right that's enough Adams let's go Gomez
was definitely taller this guy stabbed
himself and then jumped I don't buy it
[Music]
Suave son of a bee hmm I like him having
a mysterious background
get some more Lurch in the show
Catherine zeta's got that perfect walk
down but I'm happy to report that the
Eugene is on the mend and it's expected
to make a full recovery what the real
Eugene showed him to me trying to coma
have you been to see him okay so he is
alive to look at my family
talk about toxic pack mentality I give
my mom 30 seconds before her judgy claws
come out
claws are a metaphor how are you my
little Wayne Club I thought thing was
filling you in on my every move
so how's the little fella doing
he's still stealing the show since
you've abandoned me here I've been
hunted haunted and the target of an
attempted murder
ah Nevermore I love you so
flashing back to the Glory Days look at
you
yes Gabrielle hasn't shown her face
since I started here
probably sounding herself somewhere on
the seashells my darling daughter
oh
I made it
wouldn't miss this for the world
she looks horrified do you remember when
we did that duet your Judy Garland
impression was a Dead Ringer
sounds positively
let's do it my picture's gone
really well that is odd
Wednesday's assimilation has been Rocky
at best because I refuse to embrace the
culture of dishonesty and denial
permeating the school
my girl Dr kimbert and I have spoken and
we both agree it would be most
beneficial for you all to attend a
family session this weekend oh wow
that's gonna be good what can I heard I
mean to be honest I've always been a big
fan of hair shrinking
go see Trader Sam it's hard to stomach a
murderer wander around town scot-free
at least they care enough about
Wednesday to go to therapy with her ah
tape off the scene I'll be right there
you okay what's going on
you know Reggie the local coroner
he just blew what whoa
why would he do that
oh you get food in therapy there maybe
we can discuss what it's like having
Wednesday away from home
it's been hard not having Wednesday
around oh I never thought I'd miss being
waterboarded so much
into good time Pugsley and good time
who was Garrett Gates and why are you
accused of murdering him
whoa I know your father's an innocent
man local sheriff doesn't seem too
convinced Wednesday stop
it was neither the time nor the place
actually this is exactly the place these
sessions
it's not concern you you're getting
defensive Tish
thanks for the candy actually that's
potpourri
why don't you say something earlier yeah
come on I was wondering it's kind of
weird that they were eating in therapy
How Could You Ambush your father like
that you insisted I go to this school
did you really think I wouldn't find out
your secret you don't know story
your father did nothing wrong I'll be
the judge of that a good time for a
vision it sort of looked like he
murdered him how did you find me Morning
Song Community misses you they gotta
find another place to congregate the
only place in town it's time to come
that place was never my home Gideon said
you'd resist don't say that man's name
to me you think he'd give a damn about
some single mom or her daughter if we
weren't Sirens that is no way to talk
about your stepfather oh damn
my siren song is drying up
recruitment numbers are way down and the
wrong people are starting to ask
questions
wasn't a request this is a sudden plot
you got until the end of the weekend to
say your goodbyes show some unlikely
friends it was making me care about
Bianca thanks for keeping an eye on him
he didn't deserve this
that should be in that bad
why did you go without me she's is
getting emotional you must be Wednesday
Eugene's moms Sue and Janet oh
so excited to finally make a real
well I brought him some money Eugene
loves those dang bees like they're his
kids
his fuzzy Buzzy babies oh
he's gonna be okay
look how uncomfortable she is I know we
got security footage black bubble gum
got them scrubbing through video to find
out how long it's been there black
bubble gum
damn it he felt guilty about an old case
he says he covered it up faked the
coroner support and has been living with
that guilt for all these years it's a
setup
case uh Garrett Gates
you heard of him
I'll wait 30 years to put away his
murder what a weird timing
[Music]
oh that looks delicious we're not hungry
dog
my appetite eludes me mother
the same way the truth alludes you
the Niger appetite for justice
we need to tell them
she'll never believe us you'd be
surprised truth will set you free
it's kind of interesting to portray the
parents like
almost antagonistic Ajax and I haven't
defined our relationship yet I'm not
talking about
have you walked out yet the judgmental
Claw is coming out no
well that is a disappointment
it's me
just wait till episode eight
no you're not gonna arrest him oh my God
you're under arrest for the murder of
Garrett Gates do the right to remain
silent anything you say Canon will be
used against you in a court of law oh
this is [ __ ] well I got nipples from
everyone too
[Music]
oh buddy
how's your mother devastated she hates
you in Orange
[Laughter]
is the hard color to pull off it all
came to a head the night of the Raven
dance
system protects Predators he's Twisted
enough for your mother had made him
insane
his eyes pour into me brimming with
murderous intent go get out of here he
won't hurt me what were his powers
by jealousy and hate Gary was
Unstoppable oh
damn
[Music]
this dude is extremely jealous
almost seems like he's possessed of
something
when I saw the sword
s
it's rabid it was a terrible accident
why wouldn't Wednesday believe this
has a really good effect
had really good timing his confession
sounds entirely plausible perhaps my
father is exactly what he says thank you
for being so honest with me uh perhaps
not but then there's the matter of his
toes
the way he smoothed his mustache the way
he delivers a comforting wink
I've been playing Russian roulette with
him since I was 12.
haha who's sorry I wasn't a better
father how many fathers hand their
daughter a fencing blade when she's five
years old
you say The Strokes were an essay in
Perfection we'll teach you how to swim
in sharks they found you as cold-blooded
and I do
father of the year you taught me how to
be strong and
how to navigate myself
and Prejudice you are the reason I
understand how imperative it is that I
never lose sight of myself
touching so as far as fatherhood goes I
would say you've been more than adequate
wow well a Sentimental sentence Bernice
may or may not have received a call that
her tabby cat Swifty is being held for
ransom
all I see is a guilty man is finally
going to pay for his crime
covered in myself oh that was the icing
on the cake such a prick I found the
monsters cave and I gave you the DNA
evidence
did you even bother to test it no match
inconclusive whoever hurt Eugene also
murdered the coroner unfortunately
someone sabotaged the security camera
and the morgue so we don't know what
happened
this is all a distraction no this is
about Justice being served Garrett
Gates's family deserves closure even if
none of them are around to take comfort
in it his mother herself in the backyard
his father drank himself to an early
grave and even his little sister didn't
Escape that was darkest [ __ ]
ended up drowning oh every last one of
them's gone no there's a cover-up
happening here so someone knows how to
cover things up to make it look like
they're often themselves
happy wolf summer camp
speed up the wolf process
uh
so camps for like cantherby conversion
I need to be dramatic in it you want to
send me to conversion therapy for
werewolves what wonders for your cousin
Lucille didn't it
speak up Dad you forgot your fishing
gear
stop trying to be nice
doesn't suit you father packed your
favorite bait severed fingers
foreign
[Laughter]
let's see if the fish are biting
[Laughter]
it's quite a catch God damn
you have to find out the truth and free
dad well until that happens we both know
mother will be falling apart look at
that Focus damn which means we have to
be strong and by we I mean you
you're the glue now Pugsley give me one
of those
I love these shots they out of the
out-of-focus backgrounds under the lake
the light reflecting on them great
contrast between all the colors and then
they're monochromatic palette so you're
a Nightshade actually I rejected them
I'll never live up to your legacy here
I win the Poke up you claimed it four
times
I joined the fencing team you captained
it
damn the group was started by an
ancestor of your fathers from Mexico
goody I saw her painting at Pilgrim
world how ironic since she was the one
who killed Joseph craigstone the night
shades were her secret but deadly
answered to his oppression whole answers
father didn't kill Garrett Gates did he
you did I found your father fighting for
his life it was terrifying
[Music]
I'll never forget the way he looked at
me
he was even foaming at the mouse yikes
it was like I was staring into the eyes
of a rapid piece looks like crisp and
Glover that guy that's love baby
[Music]
okay
[Music]
my father was so
calm it's a good man
true love
can you believe right now go to your
room and lock the door you were never
here his voice does sound like him
that's a good match evil when they
cleared him if anyone
someday this would come back
and not in the fun way there's still
self-defense though you said Garrett was
filming at the mouth
his eyes didn't look human
well maybe it wasn't rage at all
filming saliva dilated pupils mental
confusion what are those all textbook
symptoms of
Adderall is
troll how can that mean
there's only one way to find out
[Music]
that devilish smile oh yes when you got
your first grade taking kid he was so
happy you made me smiling
I was right
well well what do we have here guess is
going to be an Adams Family Reunion and
lock up tonight even how she puts up her
hands
you get comfortable you can post bail in
the morning
it's a souvenir from our outing
I borrowed it from Garrett
he died from Nightshade poisoning
Garrett was dying before you stabbed him
he would have survived the fall
oh God
damn yikes
interesting how history seems to keep
repeating itself he had a vial of
nitrade poison that broke in his pocket
he wasn't just trying to kill father he
was going to use the Nightshade poison
to murder the entire school now how can
you prove this that blue sheen is a
Telltale sign of nightshade poisoning
but you already knew that because back
when you were Sheriff you were in charge
of the case and covered it up
who was corn oh the corner yeah why did
you instruct Dr Anwar to falsify the
autopsy report you knew the truth now if
there had been a trial both Jericho's
and nevermore's reputations would have
been trashed I think the only reputation
you were worried about ruining was your
own
Garrett bragging to me that his father
had the sheriff in his pocket
one year later you get elected mayor
real credit to the force you could have
prevented Garrett's death if you had
done your job when I lodged my complaint
about him stalking me men like you have
no idea what it feels like not to be
believed
oh topical
you too huh what do you want
for Gomez to be let out of prison yeah
[Laughter]
I should also tell the church to the
sheriff
ah let him figure it out in his own
times
sometimes when I touch someone or
something
you get these very violent glimpses from
the past or future our psychic ability
resides on the spectrum of who we are my
Visions tend to be positive that makes
me a dove
you're a raven
your Visions are more potent more
powerful like the dance Raven somebody
from my bloodline reaches off from
Beyond to help us
goody goody has be careful Wednesday
but he was a witch of great strength but
her Vengeance pushed her too far and
even she couldn't save herself tell her
the whole story
the most Clear Vision you've had
I don't know gorgeous
only blood deaths
your daughter and my son have become
close I pity any boy who gets caught in
a Viper's gaze but he must be a good egg
he asks his mom to thank for that
what if it's the mom who is the monster
nope it's Tyler It's gotta be
[Music]
perfect in the role man I'm not going
if I'm into wolf out then I'm going to
do it on my own timeline and not yours
got it goddamn right at the end of this
episode
proud of you kiddo
I'm hip with the kids I was hoping he
sounded more like this
I'm proud of you kiddo wait until the
school year is over how do I know you
won't run away again because she gets a
spin-off I knew you didn't have what it
takes to be a murderer
as much as there's things
could I see this my little death trap
all the wonderful times I had here
you have your
and you're making quite the impression
like the themes of this episode
[Music]
oh
thought she might do it yeah
last episode it'll be a big group hug I
did win as Roan getting murdered that
night excuse me when Rowan appeared the
next morning it was you what
talent show with my mother not only did
you impersonate Judy Garland you became
her
ah
is it Immaculate pause Rowan's father
already knows what happened and he fully
supports my decision not to involve the
authorities oh his telekinetic abilities
were driving him mad and he attempted to
murder you twice his tragic death
allowed us to rectify this situation
without casting the school or Rowan in
an unflattering light
a lot of cover-ups I did what I needed
to do to Shield the school for
controversy and protect its students
from half tell that to Eugene
how are you protecting him oh God
please do not let anything terrible
happen to Eugene
after it's already happened once
[Music]
fire will rain oh my
great shot nice reflection
fire will rain was that spelled
correctly for that
uh depending not good good symmetry
four-letter words rain fire rain yeah
elements yeah they were like you know
region just throws the whole thing off
that's too much letters yeah fair enough
fair enough that's one mystery solved
all right another good episode getting
another mystery out of the way one Mr
resolved and but uh what I really liked
about it because I thought the mystery
of Gomez Adams
uh and the murder the murder case here
would I thought I'd get hey I thought I
could resolve later and B I thought that
it would perhaps tie more directly into
the immediate plot line sure of the
mystery of who's the monster and the
cover-ups there I mean but it does still
enhance the current storylines that
we're dealing with for example like
unpacking the fact that there's so much
cover up so that is a part of the
hierarchy here is that the rich remain
in power the powerful like to cover
things up and it's all about the image
protection and whatnot so I think
um that ties into there but what I did
appreciate most about what this episode
did with even though they got out of the
way on the fifth episode and it doesn't
exactly go to serve the main story
um it it enhanced the character
development of Wednesday like with
uncovering you know her connection with
her dad like I love the scene with him
in the jail and her talk because there
is that divide where she's closer she's
like a tomboyish kind of person is that
offensive now every word I say now I'm
always like yes it's Tom Bush I've ever
heard anyone say it but an offensive
thing to say to someone yeah I don't
know I don't know uh you let us know but
I'm gonna fall on the side of it's all
right I'll just say the qualities of the
kind of individuals she was shaped into
who are in large part due to the type of
nurturing relationship she had with her
father
and yet even though she's more like her
mom in a lot of ways at least when you
kind of look on the surface
she's more adapted to the more depth to
the world around her because of her dad
and so this enhanced that relationship
because so much of why she is
emotionally the way she she comes across
whether it be closed off or what she
cares about or her interests are is so
much to do with her parents and this
episode does so much with uh defining
yourself and not being defined by your
family which it's not like a negative
thing it's it's something I think a lot
of people deal with especially
adolescence of learning to grow into
your own and not feel like you have to
just
you know uh go through with upholding
whatever it is that your parents really
want for you to do but be be who you are
and so there and it kind of did both of
establishing like no there's a lot of
good things she got but she really is
her own person and they it kind of
reflects through with Enid and it shows
like the the uh generational trauma that
can be inherited through the other
characters especially going through the
past so I thought I'd at least served
maybe not on the plot line it didn't
directly affect the whole thing of like
who's the monster and the murders that
are happening now it does segue into her
discovering via yearbook who uh
Gwendolyn Christie really is but it at
least gave a lot of character
development that uh and to me that's
arguably more important yeah I thought
it would do a little bit more for the
sheriff since that was such a big part
of his introduction yeah it was like
Jordan Adams I hate the ABS Gomez Adams
lifelong Vendetta sorry about that
in my son what are you gonna do yeah
um so yeah I I enjoy I enjoyed the
episode it's not my favorite out of the
five that we've seen so far but I still
really liked it and I still thought it
moved the story forward and the
character our main character forward in
really nice ways yeah absolutely I think
the the addition of a parent's day
especially at a place where you go and
you know you board a boarding school I
feel like has to be something of a a
both cathartic but also tense experience
because you know anytime I feel like a
parent comes into the academic
environment there's sort of a reason to
be sort of on edge and also too
everyone's at that age but yeah I liked
seeing everybody's different uh family
makeup and what they have to yeah play
off of but also what informs them as
characters and even though like the
thing with Enid is is not like the most
original idea ever I appreciated just
the the characterization of everybody or
Bianca's mom just getting Yeah a
different view into what each character
has to deal with and why they might
behave the way they do at school without
their parents you know because of what
they're trying to these Shadows they're
trying to escape or the paradigms that
they're trying to break free of that
they feel like are being forced upon
them for one reason or another and I
think that they've done a nice job of of
painting a good array it seems like you
know Bianca's mother is in you know
something uh more of uh maybe not like
nefarious but something more of a uh you
know
it seems like she may be up to more
overt no good than just being
overbearing doubt it like
uh you know like Enid's parents or
something like that but even getting to
see uh Eugene's family uh briefly for a
moment and kind of getting a clue as to
how and why he is so sweet amid this you
know array of other more prickly
outcasts and whatnot and and yeah having
The Adams Family here for an episode was
also just a nice it was smart because
it's it's a tension Adder for everyone
in general but it also gets you some
time with The full-on Adams Family which
like I loved getting a little bit of
bonding between Wednesday and Pugsley
and I I found actually the MGM has uh at
least like a season's worth there's like
15 episodes worth of just old Adams
Family episodes just on YouTube for
anyone to watch and and part of the like
looking back at those episodes part of
the charm is like oh yeah like Wednesday
and Pugsley are often Palling around and
you know getting into Mischief together
and even though this is playing more of
a you know more of a dramatic angle on
that their relationship is strained I
still found it very charming and and the
actor who plays Pugsley for the brief
amount of time we've seen him I thought
it was very Charming to get the two of
them together to get one-on-one moments
with everybody but also to get you know
like the awkward family therapy scene
and stuff like that and then the
interrogation or not the interrogation
but you know like in the
the jailhouse with uh Gomez in Wednesday
and sort of seeing those moments where
like I thought they gave a nice array of
moments in this episode to confront yeah
the family trauma but also to touch on
the love that does exist there and I
think Jenna Ortega continues to really
excel at showing the love that exists on
beneath the surface even though she is
very very averse to expressing it and uh
and yeah I love characters like that who
you can tell something means I love you
when it sounds and looks like anything
but that and you know that's bread and
butter of The Addams Family
um and yeah just Louise Guzman and uh
Catherine Zayden Jones I really enjoyed
across this episode and and the the
matches in the past both in the casting
and just the way they played all that
stuff through the flashback I thought
was really gripping uh yeah yeah like I
don't know if I would mark it as my
favorite episode either but it does feel
like it it's one I would remember out of
the series as being you know the the fun
Adams Family only episode and I
appreciate that we got that too yeah I
feel like it's sort of uh it easily
could have felt perfunctory like we need
to do an Adams Family episode and we you
know because sometimes you can feel
forced and it it didn't feel forced this
is a storyline they had to deal with and
again enhancing the characters and on
top of that too it does good World
building you know it's setting up the
stakes
between it's almost like an X-Men type
of deal yeah or if Muggles in The
Wizarding World hated Wizards you know
yeah like if hogsmeade was the round the
corner from like a regular human town
and they had to kind of and and the way
that they touch on that like there's so
many reasons to be like ah you Jericho
bastards are always conniving against us
but it's really like I did think that as
much as the the mayor is not a stand-up
guy that idea of like I was trying to
protect the well-being of Nevermore
Engine America because they're both
gonna fall into this trap yeah yeah I
think they did a good job there I I
think my and I wonder how it would feel
because I know most people binge this
show and this is really kind of a slight
because I really did enjoy this episode
overall I I liked it quite a bit uh for
all the reasons I said and I wouldn't
want it to not be here I did feel that
there was something about the way the
pacing was from the first to the fourth
episode
that kind of felt like it was ramping up
it was it was like really ramping up and
and uh it was just so it was flowing so
well and this kind of felt like
I don't want to say an interruption but
it did kind of mess with the pacing a
little bit it was definitely on the
slower side and granted I know some
stuff that we might say might that might
sound like a contradiction because I'm
like yeah I love the pacing I like when
it breathes and while I do like that I
guess I guess in the world of Wednesday
atoms of what of the show Wednesday
I'm not as particularly drawn to the
actual Adams Family characters as I am
the other cast members that we've been
hanging out with and that might be just
like
it might just be on me and I imagine
that is not a common consensus and a
common opinion it's like I enjoy them
and I really like watching them uh but I
think because it's like the fifth
episode we're now like taking a detour
to focus solely on them it made me you
know I found myself like oh but I've
been so into everyone else's storyline
that I've kind of just that's where my
heart's been at I bet you that means
you're halfway on that because like for
me as a viewer it's exciting and fun
like I I appreciate this as The Addams
Family episode but in being so it does
feel more like an interlude in the
middle of the season with a side mystery
versus yeah the overarching feeling like
it really
fully kept the overarching momentum of
the show going yeah and I I liked
Gwendolyn Christie for the BR we don't
really get much of her
when you think about it we don't really
get a lot of her
which I think that kind of performance
too is something that could also be it I
don't I don't know how much credit she
really gets for a performance here maybe
she shines a lot more in the later
episodes because I I feel like whenever
she's there she brings a lot even in
like the most
sometimes in just like the reactions she
gives and the way her and Jenna Ortega
play off of each other is really well
executed and I love the the sense of
history that she carries with her in
almost every moment that she's on screen
yeah I think that resonates really
strong so I really love like I loved
like the last few minutes of this when
she does piece together and that's more
of like the mystery solving that I want
to see more of like I know they had like
a minor complaint about the end of
episode two of wanting to like kind of
be there with her and I think like oh
yeah that's a good that's a good way to
uh for her to figure it out yeah to put
one and one together I thought that was
a good mystery solving
um for
what was his name Rowan Rowan yeah yeah
with what happened with Rowan and it's
well motivated in the dialogue to the
point where by the end of the episode it
doesn't feel like just a random
occurrence or a random like contrivance
of the plot or something and I agree
like Gwendolyn Christy she she's really
good at always seeming so High Str like
so put together but also so high strung
that like everything is like just
beneath the surface ready to break
through and she has to kind of keep this
Poise and I I think there's uh yeah a
lot of magic to what she does like
whenever she's on screen and even the
actors that got to play the younger
version of her like even though it was a
recast and and whatever I noticed it but
at the same time in the moment I was
like oh great like this still feels like
the same character I do wish I really do
if there's one part of this that I I do
wish we we definitely got
it that we could have received as an
audience is a better scene after Gomez
is let out and between him and the
sheriff because that sheriff has been
that's been on this guy's mind for 30
years part of his life and I felt like
that scene just didn't quite I like I
like the latter half of it about talking
about like hey maybe the essentially
implying like maybe our futures can be a
little bit different because look at our
children bonding with each other right
like I I get that because the show deals
so much with I mean the town itself is
so much of a history a generational
trauma situation you're dealing with and
it's like trying to keep the peace
between people with powers and normies
and I did think like there there could
have just been a little bit more meat on
that one scene oh totally when after all
that because it was just kind of like
but but I will say
that there is of one part of my brain
that goes well they've done a lot to
also establish that the sheriff is not
exactly the most emotional guy
so he might just be the kind of Interest
like whoopsie you know and I'm like I
I'm not really gonna talk about it but
he's just be like sorry about that you
know I think you could still make a
scene with that yeah learn something I I
don't know what he would have learned
but uh but at least at least more of a
moment I think yeah yeah yeah at least
more of an acknowledgment of of hey I
was wrong I'm sorry for holding this
grudge against you for so many years and
going out of my way to try and apprehend
you in the process yeah yeah that was a
that was one part of the that's one part
of this and I was like oh I did I did
feel like I needed that yeah and
acknowledge I mean and it would give you
an opportunity to acknowledge the way
he's treated Wednesday up till this
point too but yeah and I and I don't
know what the original uh Gomez I'm not
familiar with like the original what is
it comic literature what was newspapers
what New York or comic strip or
something like that I'm not familiar
with what the um OG
uh representation is I don't mean that
in ethnic wise uh a depiction of Gomez
Adams is like but you know from knowing
like Raul Julia and generally how Gomez
Adams is is portrayed it is nice to get
a more like subtle Gomez atoms sure I do
like what he actually brings to the
table and uh I do enjoy Catherine Zeta
Jones and they do have they don't have
like electric chemistry but they do have
a nice chemistry with each other they're
not quite Rel Julia and Angelica Houston
in that department but they yeah but I I
enjoy them sketchy sometimes yeah yeah
sure that's a good way to put that I
like them very much individually and I'm
happy for the moment but even even
something about the way they realize
because like him kissing all up and down
her arms is kind of a Trope of the outer
family and I feel like even the way they
handled that was like one of the more
slightly less natural things that the
episode tried to do
um so I mean yes it's not it's not like
a big deal that I'd hold against it but
that's what makes me as a viewer go like
oh wow I want to get more time with them
so I could feel like Morticia and Gomez
have
I don't know I just feel like the more
time you spend on screen the more they
get to play the more you know that
Dynamic and that Rapport will develop
and feel as time is it's I almost bought
their relationship more as the flashback
characters yeah and that might have been
too because of such a high stakes
situation there's so much emotion to
bring out of of a scene like that you
know so whereas there's there's is
always sort of that like
spooky ghoulish undertone with them and
it's it is fun and I like their yeah I
like their individual scenes a lot and I
I I I love the way this show is shot I
really love the cinematography like the
the reflective lighting that they always
do and there's some great like blending
with I notice it a lot with hair and
background they do an excellent job with
color schemes and I I'm so impressed to
it's good to get a show where like they
put more effort into this than like a
Marvel movie I know part of me wants to
look at that like the scope of
in wanting to praise the visuals like oh
well I'd love to take a look at this
side by side with some other Netflix
stuff because that's a common complaint
about stuff like Marvel but also even
like Netflix shows or streaming shows in
general is like things are shot with
this sort of flat array of colors so you
can kind of do anything but I feel in
post but here it always feels like the
vibrancy and the contrast of the colors
is really on point and Vivid
um so yeah I would I would definitely
agree with that yeah it pops I love I
just love the aura of everything all
around so yeah I still really enjoy this
episode a lot and and I had a little bit
more desire I guess for some stuff I
wouldn't really call it like criticism I
have more desire for some things to feel
a little bit more for but I I don't want
that to I really wouldn't want that to
read as
got issues yeah yeah it's it's it's it's
that thing of like it's not necessarily
missing something there's just stuff I
would have liked more of yeah
let's go away put it alrighty guys what
did you think about The Adams Family and
Bianca that sounds like spin-off oh
there's no how can you do that in in
three in the next three episodes
are there set up for season two or a
spin-off right Wednesday and Bianca are
gonna go to the the whatever the siren
place is called and they're gonna buddy
cop team up and uh and figure out what's
going on there
you know I I've I sometimes read the top
comments on the I get afraid to go to
scroll through comments on these videos
I apprecially the comment uh again I'll
I'll look through them after we're done
filming uh all them I get afraid to go
too deep because whenever we're binging
a show I'm like don't go too deep
because you can spell some [ __ ] so um I
only read the top comments sometimes
they're the ones you see hearted and uh
and and I have noticed some top comments
have pointed out that General Ortega
didn't want to
um like insisted that there's not a love
triangle here
and that they they wanted to honor that
request or something that Echoes
something like that but I feel like the
show does do it like like we keep being
reminded of it but I'm like we're five
episodes in it and it seems to point to
to it and like a romance it absolutely
does and I think it works really well
and I bet it'll I I could absolutely 100
see it coming out in the end where she
was just like yeah I just like both of
you as friends and that's it you know
I'm not really interested in this and I
feel like that could be the twist of
that aspect of the story because I think
they certainly want it to read that way
yeah yeah yeah even the way of how Gomez
talks about with the sheriff about I'd
be worried about anyone that my daughter
sets her deadly Viper eyes on or some
[ __ ] yeah yeah that that would be that
that's that's definitely part of that I
don't know it's not a really big deal to
me but it's interesting to note though
yeah and because it seems like Jenna
Ortega does have a fair amount of input
at least control over this thing Dwayne
Johnson she is now yes the Ryan Reynolds
of being Wednesday Adams yeah
choreographed my dance I rewrite my
lines I don't want this for the
character I'm 20 years old season two
written directed produced and started
uh she does seem to have it or it just
sounds like they they respect creative
contribution as the best idea wins it
might be the sentiment around the set of
Wednesday uh because that's what it
sounds like she seems like so much
credit goes to her like uh her ideas and
her request and I think that's that's
really cool it's almost unheard of I
know for that to be such a conversation
surrounding a show too like it seems
like a a thing I've heard just people
out there talking about you know it's a
common sentiment so it's cool to see
that uh see see such a good show come
out of it
alrighty guys well what did you think
about this episode leave your thoughts
down below you can subscribe leave a
like leave a like last but not least we
always end this with a patreon
Tyler Hague if I was Morticia
you would be my Gomez yeah and I would
just want to kiss you up and down from
head to toe all day every day and never
stop showing my affection for you
because in some ways you are like the
Gomez Adam this Gomez Adam there's
somebody you are like the Gomez atoms of
our patreon pages
always loving and super adorable
enthusiastic I don't get the impression
that you're tall you seem like a shorter
fella
you know you could be like I've seen you
from here to here so I'm not really sure
but you you have a three feet tall child
like teddy bear sincerity about you and
I adored that and I'll never ever forget
so much of the energy of yours that you
have shared with us throughout the years
and I look forward to just keep talking
with you buddy and whenever we make our
trip out to Wisconsin which will be in
like 20 years I'm taking a road trip
because
I don't think I'm ever gonna fly to
Wisconsin what's out there
if you're around in L.A
let me know I'll buy you a drink buddy
yeah and let us know what's in Wisconsin
might be something worth checking out
maybe I'm a shopping mall sure a Green
Bay Packers game and red letter media we
could go visit redlander media there you
go
they just let you visit yeah you could
just walk in that's how Macaulay Culkin
gets there sure they love reaction
channels they love exactly what we do
here and they find Great Value in it
they adore it
but we value and adore you Tyler thank
you Tyler
[Music]